the first thing that we did was talk
about uh spinning in a hallway as an
analogy for keeping your points nice and
clean and knowing where they're oriented
and where you are it's one thing to
visualize this in your head that helps
but to physically do it where your
physically referencing something
especially a real hallway with real
walls and it will help four cardinal
directions in a hallway if you're
standing down the hallway looking down
the hallway you can draw a circle on the
the left and the
right if you make a quarter turn you
will be facing one wall and both of your
circles will be happening on that one
wall if you make another quarter turn
you will be facing the other way down
the hallway spinning the reverse for
instance
qu turn you're facing the other wall now
your hands are both on that wall but
they're circling the other way so it's
another direction to kind
of and when you make one more quarter
turn you've gone through all four
cardinal directions and you're back to
where you you started what be able to do
that in either direction if my PO are
like train wheels and I'm on the train
and the Train's rolling that way as long
as I keep my PO planes lined up and I
don't stop them or turn them around
funny or
something no matter what I do the train
still rolling that way here's split Time
same direction here split Time same
direction split Time same direction
split Time same direction always the PO
are always rolling the same way even
though I'm changing the direction that
my playy wheels spin never changes until
I want it
to oh look now I'm in butterfly this
this is really the cool thing about this
whole four cardal Direction thing it
works with everything now I'm spinning
opposite directions any basic sort of
spinning that you can
do you can turn through all of these
four cardinal directions in eventually
lots of different ways let's start with
the simple ones and work out more there
one of the other things that we' played
with which I really like to do is just
kind of spin your poy on a on a plane
and right now I'm kind of lining up at
the edge of the map and play kind of
moving around it keeping deoy in the
same place more often than not spendy
moving around us not toss around poy and
it's good to play with that other
thing there's a moment where when you
cross over the wall and flip to the
other side you have to do a little
figure8 to flip your poy over the other
side so
yourself and it doesn't just have to be
simple spinning you can apply this
exercise to gain control awareness in
any sort of move like
[Applause]
maybe I'm constantly
doing a two petal flower there's no
reason to just do it with one you could
in in a number of ways you can turn
around with both poo but I I as an
applied example we play with buz saww
and how to slowly and in control turn
around with bua so we're walking around
the bus trying to keep it in place and
so that it can't hit my arm there I got
to flip the hand I'm turning away from
so that it's facing the wall from this
new direction that allows me to keep
going a little bit more no I'm going to
hit my arm again so now I have to see
how one is out in front one is behind I
need to switch who's far and who's near
keep coming around until I can put my to
in
Reverse we're starting with very simple
movement but you can build on it and
build on it into all these fountains and
other really crazy moves that when
someone just tries to learn it as a
trick there's so much going on it's
really overwhelming but if you learn
this as a foundation first it's just
like oh right I just do that thing but I
kind of move around a little bit it's a
much easier step than everything at once
then we put our POI down and the rest of
the class is pretty much POI without POI
how the body moves so that your POI can
move better we stood one on either side
of our invisible wall and we did some
exercises the idea is that we're always
trying to keep our our hands kind of
lined up on this wall we're always
touching our hands so if we have
physical feedback make sure that we are
touching that plane not W way up here
and we want to check our cor cardinal
directions start to allow our
torso to turn with
it we up the an a little bit start doing
F time opposes
then we all lined up a friend or like a
post or something that's not going to
move on you and we get stuff in the
hallway this how your right hand could
be touching that imaginary right wall
and go ahead and put that forward on the
right wall you see how as long as you're
touching the wall the imaginary wall
you're not actually smacking your
partner in front of you now take your
left hand put it up in the air and snap
F and put it back behind you without
so as long as it's over there touching
the wall you're not actually smacking
someone in the face or anything like
that let's go ahead and swim forward
snap high and
low horizontal High the right goes
forward down back up forward down back
up just pay attention to the person in
front of you if the timing shifts it'll
kind of Ripple through this line just
keep time with the person in front of
you okay now we're going to go in
reverse right hand up back down forward
up back down forward you see how our
torsos are all kind of turned towards
the China lights right this time we're
going to scoop our hands up the China
Lights until we're like holding an
imaginary China Light looking forward
out the window and we're going to snap
and drop down The Horizon looking at the
exit wall all the way down by the hips
and snap shine of Lights Lantern exit
wall hips chates Lantern exit wall hips
now this time ready we're going to let
our arms drop
down scoop it up the exit wall up to the
lantern back
down your hands are always staying on
the same sides they're roating in
opposite direction torso twisting back
and forth there's all this stuff going
on at the same
time it just so happens that those those
four different kind of time Direction
modes four different
symmetries are the Bedrock of almost all
poy there's not too much you can do with
POI that doesn't involve it somehow
falling into one of those four
categories so if you get once again get
comfortable with those E4 as Basics
everything else kind of grows from there
then we did footwork
think in terms of stepping and turning
as uh intertwined when you when you make
a front side turn half turn you've also
taken a step and of course you can step
back as
well we played with that we played with
then combining
those so stepping front side then
stepping back side our bodies continue
to WHL while we move in a Rel very
L and then I challenge you guys to play
with that split time off of
arms what made that all a little less
overwhelming is that as we're turning
and stepping it helps to be able to spot
where you're going and where you're
leaving and that happens to line up
really nicely with where your focus
points for your hands are so instead of
thinking about doing all all these
different things at once if you can
really just kind of harmonize it into
I'm stepping and snapping right there
second away from snapping right
there Then moving around while waving
your arms in different directions and
eventually doing flowers while you do
that like rling derish becomes way
easier